- C'était vendredi... et
le scénario se répétera lundi.
Résultat, des salles de classe
comme celle-ci seront vides.
Bon nombre de conseils scolaires
devront fermer leurs écoles,
ou encore se tourner vers
l'apprentissage en virtuel.
- On ne peut pas travailler
de faç a adéquate et avoir
des enfants qui font l'école
virtuelle.
- Omar Burgan passera son lundi
à la maison, avec ses deux
enfants.
- Chaque matin, ils nous
demandent si c'est une journée
de grveve aujourd'hui ou non.
Même nous en tant que parents,
il y a beaucoup d'incertitude.
- Ses deux enfants fréquentent
une école élémentaire ii
se tourne vers l'enseignement
virtuel jusqu'à nouvel ordre,
si la grève se poursuit.
Le fils de Mindy Sichel restera
lui aussi à la maison lundi.
- C'est difficile de trouver
une solution pour tous les trois
de travailler de la maison.
C'est assez de bruit,
c'est difficile pour lui
de se concentrer.
- C'est est un mal pour un bienr
Burgan, elle soutient la cause
des travailleurs.
- Nous nous somm r rendus
vendredi à la manifestation
pour participer. Mon fils a
eu de l'aide quand il était
au primaire des éducatrices qu
lui aidaient dans la classe.
- On ne peut pas garder
les écoles ouvertes au
détriment des travailleurs.
Les deux viennent ensemble.
Les conditions de travail
s s gens qui travaillent
dans nos écoles, c'est aussi
les conditions d'apprentissage
des élèves.
- C'est un véritable casse-tête
pour bien des parents, et
ce l'est tout autant pour
la Commission des relations
de travail de l'Ontario.
Après trois jours d'audience,
el d doit rendre sa décision,
et déterminer si le débrayage
est illégal. Une décision suivie
de près partout au pays, selon
cet expert.
- Le fait que le gouvernement
ait utilisé la clause
dérogatoire, ça fait en sorte
que ça dépasse vraiment
les limites de la province
de l'Ontario. C'est au niveau
canadien. Tout le milieu
syndical surveille
cette situation-là.
- Le Syndicat canadienee
la fonction publique tiendra
un point de presse lundi pour
faire le point sur la situation.
Il sera accompagné
de dirigeants syndicaux
nationaux et provinciaux.
Ici Rosalie Sinclair,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw